joe biden and kamala harris
are hardly deep thinkers that's the
whole point
it's the waterbug campaign right on the
surface
but if you ask them rouse them from a
dead sleep what's an
existential threat that america faces
russia
iran but number one on the list would be
institutional racism that's the biggest
threat we face neither one of them can
define that term
obviously joe biden gave a speech about
it this summer he didn't even try to
define it
he just declared that institutional
racism is everywhere
and apparently it is and they're telling
institutional racism caused kamala
harris to drop out of the presidential
primary
just as she was about to lose her home
state it's what made that minneapolis
cop
murder a man when the crops failed in
ancient rome the authorities blame the
gods but when democrats don't like
something they blame institutional
racism
you've seen a lot of this but that does
not mean that institutional racism
doesn't
exist the justice department just made a
pretty strong case that it does exist
the doj has concluded that yale
university in new haven connecticut
systematically discriminates against
asian and white applicants there's not
really any question about the evidence
to overwhelming
the doj looked at yale's admission
practices over an
18-year period what did they find quote
asian-american and white applicants have
only one-tenth to one-fourth the
likelihood of admission as
african-american applicants
with comparable academic credentials
they caught yale colt yale hasn't even
denied it really
it's true and by the way everybody knows
it's true ask any chinese or
korean-american parent you know they're
highly aware of this
their kid could have straight a's and an
amazing s.a.t score but he's not going
to princeton he'll be lucky to get into
boston college because he's the wrong
color
is there a single american who doesn't
know this
everybody knows it are we okay with that
shut up say democrats stop talking about
it it's not a real problem
as one new york times writer put it
quote justice department working
overtime for those marginalized
depressed upper class white students
able to go to yale
looking after main street as if that's
what it's about
what would be funny would be to see what
would happen if ivy league schools
stopped admitting the low iq
children of famous liberals what would
they think of that people like
cnn's chris cuomo who went to yale
because his dad was the governor of new
york
would the new york times support that
shutting down the
pipeline for the kids of democratic
politicians to brown yale princeton
harvard
oh no that would hit them where they
live
but discriminating against some korean
kid so we can feel virtuous oh yeah
we're for that
another new york times writer put it
this way quote it is not discrimination
to take into account systemic inequality
oh right so in other words it's not
discrimination to discriminate as long
as i'm the
beneficiary of the discrimination okay
so that's how it works but it's not how
the jim crow south worked
yeah but the left doesn't care about
details according to new york times if
you're an african-american student who
got a mercedes from your parents for
your 18th birthday
you were the victim of systemic
inequality you need a 200 point bonus on
your s.a.t
but if you're a kid from appalachia grew
up in a trailer park without parents had
to work your way through high school at
crystal burger
you were the beneficiary of systemic
racism
not one person believes that it's
absolutely ridiculous
it makes no sense it's insulting to all
of us it's degrading to all of us
because it's too unfair but they don't
care
the goal isn't to convince you the goal
is to make you as cynical as they
are they think they can accomplish that
and maybe they can
by rubbing their total lack of moral
standards into your face
just weeks ago the media that doesn't
care about yale's overt discrimination
against asians was horrified about the
term wuhan coronavirus because it could
hurt chinese americans they said they
never explained how but they said it
watch the president referred to the
coronavirus as a quote
foreign virus and i think it's going to
smack uh it's going to come across to a
lot of americans as smacking of
xenophobia xenophobic wartime trump
where he thinks the only path now
is to basically declare the virus public
enemy number one
painted in somewhat racist terms the
xenophobia and the racism in outbreak is
such a common thing
and it is incredibly dangerous it is
problematic and it is scary and i just
really want to call that out
why do you keep calling this the chinese
virus
why do you keep using this a lot of
people say it's racist
it's not racist at all no not at all it
comes from
china that's why it is quote
problematic and scary to criticize the
chinese government
but not to openly discriminate against
chinese american
children but you cannot criticize the
government of china anyone who does must
be silenced
white house adviser peter navarro was
actually thrown off the air for the
crime of telling cnn's viewers
where the coronavirus came from and i
will say
that this virus that is affecting the
united states right now
is the chinese you know what virus we
let you say that once peter please don't
say it again on this show i know why
china all right peter navarro we
appreciate you being with us i know what
you're trying to do there
i know why you're saying at the anchor
schools
right you're not allowed to say certain
things on the air
and cnn are msnbc or else you might
start thinking for yourself
watch the wuhan coronavirus has now
surpassed the 2003
sars outbreak the first u.s case of
chinese coronavirus
was confirmed at her house one of her
hospitals inside that building is the
world's first
lab-grown copy of the uhan coronavirus
outside mainland china
the chinese coronavirus death toll has
jumped to at least
26 people the death toll from the wuhan
coronavirus spiked today
the chinese virus the coronavirus that
is worrying the whole world
this comes as the chinese coronavirus
death toll has
jumped to at least 26 people and
sickened
at least 835 people
oh so it was okay to call it the wahan
corona virus because it is from rouhan
probably from a chinese lab actually
the evidence shows but once that became
a
public relations problem for the chinese
government
you were racist for saying it so what
can we conclude
actual racism means nothing to these
people what matters to them is whether
they can use racial division to advance
a partisan political
agenda where's the aclu in all this the
aclu spent i don't know about a hundred
years worrying about racial
discrimination
they were always left-wing they did some
pretty virtuous things
but they announced on thursday that they
have no problem with systemic racial
discrimination in college admissions
quote
calling for an end to consideration of
race in college admissions threatens the
future of campus diversity
oh in other words says the aclu we need
racism
because it brings us diversity this it
goes without saying is totally grotesque
that's why almost nobody says it out
loud
they don't want you to talk about it
because they can't defend it and in fact
once the words hit the air and people
look at them they realize wow this is
disgusting
and yet kimmel harris supports it along
with the aclu she is pushing to
eliminate the core
anti-discrimination law in california we
can't say this enough
that's how shocking it is in the 1990s
californians passed
by popular vote proposition 209.
that recognized that giving racial
preference
is wrong it's morally wrong but
democrats have changed their view now
they understand that discrimination is
key to their goals a caste system
a system in which americans are rewarded
or punished based on how they were born
allows them to take and maintain power